nous passons à notre dernier sujet elle
est la rock star de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique great attenberg
a été désigné personnalité de l'année
2019 par le magazine times cette semaine
on voit donc la jeune fille de 16 ans
une avec le titre le pouvoir de la
jeunesse
elle devient la plus jeune lauréate de
cette distinction alors rapidement créé
tâtonnements elle a commencé à
manifester à la rentrée des classes en
2018 a été tout seul devant parlement de
son pays la suède
et puis depuis c'est un gros raccourci
mais depuis elle a rallié millions de
partisans à sa cause julia de funès est
ce que vous trouvez qu'on en fait un peu
trop avec great attenberg est ce qu'à
votre avis elle sert la cause du climat
comme il faut c'est pas enfin vous le
présenter comme si c'était une
récompense et un grand mérite d'être en
une du time magazine c'est pas du tout
l'esprit de ce magazine à ils ont fait
en 1938 la une c'est et hitler staline
il n'y a pas longtemps il ya eu des
grands dix chefs djihadistes donc c'est
pas une consécration et c'est pas du
tout un prix nobel d'être en une du
times donc c'est surtout c'est en fait
ils mettent des gens influents qui ont
représenté une force qui ont eu une
influence dans l'année et en
l'occurrence on ne peut pas dire qu'elle
n'en a pas eu parce qu'elle est elle
sacrée teaser lkt elle rassemble l'air
du temps de ce qui se passe c'est à dire
le jeunisme et c'est le sous titre
le pouvoir gérer ça l'innocence port
c'est le vilain capitalisme la mort à
l'écologie enfin elle incarne tout ça
toute la morale bien pensante actuelle
donc c'est normal d'une certaine façon
qu'elle soit là c'est regrettable pour
moi parce que on peut préférer d'autres
idéologies derrière au jeunisme je
préfère le savoir et l'écologie plus
scientifique au discours démagogique qui
consiste à valoriser maintenant les
moindre symptôme bas je préfère un
discours plus réaliste et qui est pas en
train de bons sentiments et de et de
démagogie et puis au moralisme
écologique je préfère vraiment une
écologie pu à la limite plus capitaliste
plus innovantes et c'est pas forcément
contradictoire de pensée écologique
capitaliste donc c'est normal et c'est
pour moi assez regrettable
lucile schmidt dans un récent entretien
qui a donné great attenberg on peut lire
la crise écologique est aussi une crise
des droits humains de la justice et de
la volonté politique une crise créés et
alimentés par des systèmes d'oppression
coloniaux raciste et patriarcaux elle
sert qu à l'idéologie exactement greta
tête vers et je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
choses je suis pas sûr que d'abord elles
soient capables de comprendre vraiment
le sujet idéologique je pense que
l'intérêt de great attenberg c'est
plutôt ce qui se passe la dynamique
qu'elle crée du côté de la jeunesse
moi je crois pas que ce soit un sujet de
jeunisme je crois que la question est
sur le point de vue biologique vous
pensez qu'on lubac donne les ai revus
mélange non non je pense pas du tout je
pense qu'elle est tout à fait capable de
réfléchir seul je pense qu'à 16 ans on
est capable de réfléchir seul peut-être
parfois mieux qu'à 96 ans donc je pense
que non je pense qu'elle est réfléchie
seule
en revanche je pense que par rapport à
ce que ce que vous disiez julia elle est
très féru de sciences c'est une jeune
femme par exemple qui parle de boucles
de rétroaction qui en langage
scientifique extrêmement puissant et je
pense que très souvent elles parlent
davantage science quelques parcs
démocratie ou économie moi c'est plutôt
ça le reproche que je ferais annoncé
avec les vrais scientifiques non non
j'ai un exemple de scientifiques qui
disent mais finalement je suis dans
l'émotion il te manque
il ya des manquements jeu non écoutes et
arrêtés
je pense qu'elle connaît très bien les
rapports du giec et je pense qu'elle a
une capacité peut-être que c'est lié à
son légère autisme mais je pense qu'elle
sait en sciences beaucoup de choses et
il ya des fautes de sa famille est un
scientifique de mai en fin bon goûter
elle a grandi dans une famille qu'est
revenue la tâche parce qu'elles disent
soit antiscientifique ces jeux vous
permettez je pense que le débat sur ce
que la science dit au fond est un débat
extrêmement ouvert et que la science
peut être du côté de la technologie
comme elle peut être du côté du
catastrophisme tout le sujet c'est un
bon usage de la science la science en
soit c'est pas la vérité la science est
ce qu'on en fait et je pense que ce qui
est intéressant non et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que great attenberg a
opposé au contraire quelques vérités
scientifiques à une négociation
diplomatique
enlisé donc ça c'est un point sur lequel
je trouve que c'est très bien après
effectivement le times il fallait
choisir entre donald trump nancy pelosi
et great attenberg je pense qu'on
pouvait choisir ni nancy pelosi ni
donald trump quand on était le times et
je pense que la tatane berck c'était une
manière au fond c'était au fond un truc
assez pragmatique de la choisir après
moi ce que j'aime chez chez great
attenberg c'est le fait que l entraîne
avec elle des profils de jeunesse d'une
grande diversité et partout dans le
monde je crois que c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est pas le fait d'en faire
une héroïne de critiquer ce qu'elle
regrette attenberg en soi d'ailleurs on
ne le sait pas en revanche c'est devenu
une forme d'icônes et que ce soit de
l'australie à la suède en passant par
l'inde je pense que c'est assez
passionnant ce pour ne pas aller à
l'école c'est surtout ça on verra si
c'est vrai il ya eu 250 mille mètres
bien sûr que si on met de l'avant des
cols l'absence de et n'a pas au moins le
mérite d'avoir fait
d'avoir mis sur le devant de la scène la
question il faudra mais peut-être elle a
peut-être mérite mais entend enfin andy
en faire une icône c'est quand même il
ya quand même un gars passionné de
forhusce de la plus de facilité à
critiquer des pays comme la france ou
des pays européens voyez que des pays
comme la chine au com ou com
un lad et l'inde c'est une démocratie
donc greta tbac peut très bien vite afin
qu'elle n'a pas besoin de mots d'un visa
et on aimerait la voir faire le tour de
l'inde l'a peut-être que ce sera un
petit peu bousculé boycotter elle
choisit quand même d'attaquer des
démocraties qui pouvait voir et qui en
plus il faut quand même le dire la
france par exemple contribuent très
sérieusement aux efforts de la
conférence de paris si vous voulez elle
a attaqué la france voilà l
alors elle existe elle s'exprime sur le
colonialisme
bon on aimerait que le suivent ses cours
d'histoire effectivement le vendredi je
suis pas peut-être que les bobos notion
je n'en sais rien mais en histoire j'ai
pas j'ai pas l'impression qu'elle soit
aussi forte que ça moi c'est un peu mon
c'est un peu ma partie alors nous
traiter comme sur le colonialisme et moi
je suis un gaulois
j'aime beaucoup astérix j'ai beaucoup
aimé l'écrire en fait je suis si
contente d'avoir été colonisé par jules
césar en fait mais je suis content de
parler latin et je suis content qu'il
ait apporté sa belle qu'il y en ait tué
beaucoup hein
il respectait pas les droits ont dû
piler droits de l'homme ont dit les
droits des humains
voilà voilà des droits humains mais moi
je suis très content d'avoir été
connaisez mais je suis pas sûr qu'il
traite à tout bête connaisse exactement
les foires la colonisation de l'europe
par les rabbins nicolas lecaussin juste
parce que le temps file
est-ce qu'il inquiète vraiment les
grands patrons les multinationales les
milieux financiers
il faut les inquiéter parce que c'est
pas de ta faute elle s'attaque à quelque
chose qui qui qui protège en fait
la planète c'est le capitalisme parce
que ce qui sauve la planète ces
innovations c'est la science
l'innovation la technologie
c'est pour ça qu'on a inventé internet
et les mails avons envoyé des fax avec
des dizaines de papiers ça durait deux
heures pour avoir un fait maintenant on
va voir mais on économise des papiers
les arbres etc et on consomme l'énergie
électro-nucléaire donc c'est ce qui est
complètement idiot mais c'est pas
seulement pour la une du times a parlé
de nancy pelosi à qui il y avait les
gens de hong kong légende hong kong
oui ils risquent leur vie qui se bat
tous les jours qu'ils sont arrêtés qui
sont emprisonnés qui sont torturés qui
sont battus eux il méritait vraiment de
figurer à la une du times un tank
exemple pour les jeunes du monde entier
sur le figaro marcus new deal écologique
une science trop sérieuse pour être
confiée à des enfants et sophie nous dit
je trouve formidable qu'une jeune
autiste asperger se distingue ainsi
claudius nous dit ce personnage a été
fabriquée par les médias mais cela sert
au moins à sensibiliser sur la
catastrophe écologique
à la question vous vous posez great
attenberg et elle méritait d'être adoubé
personnalité de l'année par le time vous
êtes 69% à nous dire que non vous n'êtes
pas convaincu et nous terminerons cette
émission un motif qui se soigne parce
qu'on est là encore c'est le nom mais
elle a dû passer pour cette belle photo
pour cette belle photo louis pour cette
belle photo du time magazine mais parce
qu'elle ressemble un peu à jeanne d'arc
elle a dû passer trois ou quatre heures
avec des photographes toute l'équipe de
taïwan et vous aurez des comment
l'autisme devient démagogie ambiante une
vertu c'est ça qui est ça qui étonne
c'est la reconnaissance de la différence
non non pas du tout sinon c'est pas une
reconnaissance très une très grande
diversité de fort oui d'accord mais
c'est pas parce qu'on est autiste qu'on
est à plus à écouter que quelqu'un de
tout cas à des handicapés laquelle elle
a eu tout à fait raison de parler des
droits humains parce qu'aujourd'hui
continue du nombre de migrants
les personnes qui meurent dans les
inondations et les cataclysmes il ya une
vraie question sur le fait de réintégrer
de l'humanité dans cette négociation et
qu'elle le fasse maladroitement je peux
le reconnaître mais qu'en revanche le
sujet doit être mis sur la table je
pense que c'est un passage où on est
tous d'accord il ya un vrai sujet de
réchauffement climatique dont une partie
mais d'origine humaine pas tout mais une
partie très certainement d'origine
humaine
nous ici au héros de l'onu gérard et
nous terminons cette émission avec un
commentaire de babineau qui suit tous
les jours merci babineau on aime ou on
n'aime pas mais great attenberg est une
personnalité incontournable de cette
année
merci babineau et on se retrouve tous
demain à la même heure